au 1er janvier prochain je souhaite que
nos réflexions les retraites de moins de
1000 euros et qu'il n'y ait plus de son
indexation de quelques retraite que ce
soit à partir de l'année 2000 21-17
lisibilité
pourquoi encore attendre on sait qu'on
sait on propose à chaque fois coûté les
échéances d'un moment les des français
les quelques annonces on dit si déçu au
campement du magny c'est gilet jaune
écoutent attentivement le président mais
au fil des minutes leur espoir d'obtenir
satisfaction disparaissent et débute sa
conférence de presse avait l'air
intéressant on aurait dit qu'il allait
répondre à nos problèmes à ce qu'on
demandait mais ça a été tout à fait
différent par les concitoyens sur la
démocratie
emmanuel macron écarte le hérissé et la
reconnaissance du vote blanc
la fal protège puis de silence revient
en attente de mesures pour le pouvoir
d'achat
en vain tous ces gens qui sont et qui
sont vraiment une foule très nombreuse
en france qui vit dans la précarité même
des gens qui travaillent qui s'en suit
rien rien rien sur les minimas sociaux
au jour donc ça ne changera pas grand
chose pour le quotidien des gens demain
très déçue très très déçu et c'est
dommage pour lui parce que là il a
appelé les gilet jaune
allez un peu plus dans le mouvement et
un peu plus dans la colère au final le
président annonce plus de nouveaux
chantiers que de mesures concrètes
son allocution devait clôturer le grand
débat et répondre à la colère des gilet
jaune du campement du magny lui réponde
à leurs clients avec ce message